- What's up, y'all? We are back.
And earlier I showed you a
never before seen interview
with Chris Martin.
We were in New York and in that same show,
SNL's Bow and Yang
stopped by to talk about
when he realized he was a true New Yorker.
Here's a hint. It has to do with rats.
What was there a moment that you knew
you'd become a real New Yorker,
because you're not from here, right?
- I'm not from here.
- Okay. Where are you from?
- I'm from Aurora, Colorado.
- Oh, I love Colorado.
- Lovely place. Colorado's
great. Colorado's great.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- It was the town where
I cried to fix you.
I was speaking to fix you.
- That was Texas for me. Yes, yes.
- Wonderful, wonderful.
- Well, so when you, that's
very different from New York.
So when you moved here, like when did you
finally feel like "I am now a New Yorker"?
- I was eating dim sum.
And then I went to
Columbus Park in Chinatown,
and there was a pigeon
lady, very Home Alone Two.
- [Kelly] Oh my god. I was
gonna say like Home Alone.
- It was like, it was
a Home Alone situation,
Mary Poppins tuppence a bag.
- [Kelly] Yes.
- And then I saw a rat
scurry over her foot,
and then she freaked out and screamed
and I thought, wow, this
is the most New York thing
I've ever seen.
(audience laughs)
And it's funny that like,
you're chill with pigeons,
but not chill with rats.
Cause I feel like that's a package deal.
- I feel like it's a flying rat.
- God made them on the same
day, you know what I mean?
So I don't know.
- They complain about
rats in New York though,
but I'm telling you I moved to LA. Okay.
And there are rats in LA.
- Yeah, like bad rats.
- That stop, look you in the eyes,
let you know they're there,
and then scurry right off
and be like, I'm just going to go visit
my hundreds of family
members I am somewhere with.
Like, yeah. I can't stand
rats. Anyway, whatever.
So what were you? I always think this,
everybody on SNL, were you like voted
class clown in high school?
Did everybody know where you were headed?
- It was so the thing was,
the category was class clown,
but that the title of the category was
most likely to be on
SNL, which like was just,
but it was just like a
florid way of saying, oh,
he's like a ham. And he's, he's.
- You literally got Most
Likely to be on SNL?
- But, like, it, but in a way, like,
but back then it like
didn't mean anything to me.
I was like, oh, okay, cool.
- What?
- Because the prettiest person was like
most likely to be on the cover of a Vogue.
It was like that kind of thing.
- That's totally what I got.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
(audience laughs)
- They were like, she's
going to be a model.
That's, did you ever get anything?
Did you all do that where you grew up,
where you get most likely?
- No.
- You didn't do most likelies?
- No. I think, they said my school
that I was good at lots of things,
but not that good at anything.
(audience laughs)
- A Jack of all Trades.
- No, no. They said it in a nice way.
I said I'd really liked to be a pop star.
They said, well, keep dreaming.
- Oh my god.
- And look where we are now.
- Lot of people told me that too, Chris.
- Look at us now.
(audience cheers)